hi in this video I'm going to solve
another question from IIT GM
biotechnology 2013 and this question
basically asked that what would be the
correct Fischer projection corresponding
to this structure so they have given a
structure in wage form you can see they
have given a structure in the wage form
and now they ask what would be the
appropriate structure which structure
actually matches the given structure in
the question so how to proceed in this
question so best way is to write the RS
forms RS nomenclature basically RS forms
for each compounds so first our analysis
would be on this compound so we would
write the RS normal teacher and here is
an easy trick how to write the RS formal
teacher very easily and your time
efficient manner so first we have to
identify the studio centers here are two
stereos and just means to a chiral
carbons so now first we have to level
the groups attached to this chiral
carbon so if we take this chiral carbon
so first we would level this one this is
the top priority group so we would label
it as one because oxygen has the higher
molecular weight so it would be one then
we would label what we would label this
whole group this would be of our second
priority then we would label third the
methyl group now the rotation would be
like 1 2 2 then 2 3 and this rotation is
clockwise so it implies it's our
configuration if we do similarly for the
second chiral carbon bromine would be
off top priority because it has higher
molecular weight it has the highest
molecular weight actually then what will
happen after bromine second priority
would be this large group and then third
would be this ch3 then 1 2 2 & 2 2 3
the rotation is here
clockwise again it would be our
configuration okay here we don't have to
bother about the hydrogen because both
of the hydrogens are projected our back
of the plane of the paper so we can
easily see the rotation direction and we
can write whether it's our configuration
or whether it's a s configuration so for
Fischer projection what is the rule for
judging whether it's R or s so the rule
is if the hydrogen is in the sight
position then we have to do some
rotations but it is very easy let's say
so if we take this chiral carbon this
would be our top priority group because
oxygen has a higher molecular weight
then this carbon would be the the second
kind of carbon would be the second
priority groups and the third priority
group would be the ch3 so our rotation
would go 1 to 2 then 2 to 3 so this
rotation is actually an T looks like the
rotation is actually anti-clockwise so
you might be thinking it would be a s
configuration but no look at the
hydrogen hydrogen is here in this side
this means the hydrogen is projected
upward from the plane of the paper it's
not projected behind the plane so that
is why if we have to give one conversion
then we would write it R so it looks
like s but we would write R so the here
is the trick it would look like s but if
the hydrogen is here we would just write
the opposite configuration so let's try
again with another
chiral Center for this chiral Center
bromine would be top priority and then
second priority would be this whole
group and third would be these ch3 so
our rotation would go like 1 to 2 then 2
to 3 so it is anti-clockwise rotation so
you would be thinking anti-clockwise
rotation so it s no hydrogen is in this
position so it looks like s but it would
be R actually so this R this is the
trick by applying this trick you can
easily see whether the nomenclature is R
or s so it's very easy to
so here we write our our for both studio
Center and from the above wage structure
we also get that there we have our our
so this option is probably the correct
option but still we have to for safety
we have to look other options also so
let's check option B
top priority would be O then it would be
the second priority group and this would
be three so it would rotate like this in
a clockwise fashion
it looks like our but it would be s as
the hydrogenous here if hydrogen is like
a horizontal in this kind of condition
we have to change its configuration it
looks like s but it would be
it looks like our but actually it would
be s so let's analyze this again
stereocenter bromine would be top
priority then it would be like second
priority and the third priority would be
ch3 so our rotation would be one two
then three
it looks like our but actually it would
be s would this clockwise it looks like
our because that but it would look like
s because hydrogen is here so here we
get a s s configuration
so this would not be correct option this
analyze option C option C here it is OAH
its 1 this would be 2 and this would be
3 so the rotation would be 1 to 2 to 3
it is anti-clockwise it would look like
s but it would be actually our as the
hydrogen is over here now according to
the second stereocenter Romania is 1
this would be second priority and this
would be 3 so 1 then 2 2 2 3 this is the
clockwise rotation so it would look like
our but it is actually s so here the
configuration is our s it doesn't match
with the question the the particular
structure given in a wedge form so it
won't be the option ok I came in the
same formula this please analyze these
last structure so for first this would
be top priority group because it has
oxygen bound to it then this carbon
along with all this group would be the
second priority this would be the third
priority rotation would go like 1
two two two two three this is the
rotation direction in this clockwise
this is a clockwise rotation direction
but it would be actually s because
hydrogen is over here so as it is s
whether the second carbon is RR s
doesn't matter
this option is incorrect so we need both
our hope you liked this video please
like and sub